good evening Tesco will pay its first
regular dividend since 2014 after
reporting its best results since that
year four-year sales rose by 1.3 percent
to 50 7.5 billion pounds with underlying
operating profits up by 28 percent to
1.6 four billion pounds those figures
don't yet include sales from the cash in
carriage I'm Booker which Tesco bought
for 4 billion pounds in march with dave
McCarthy's head of consumer retail in
Europe at HSBC knee joins me now Dave
great to see you now is it too
simplistic to say this is all Jan to
just cutting thousands of middle
management jobs and then recycling it in
price cuts yes there's a lot more to it
than that what you've said is a key part
of it but there's been massive
improvement in the overall offer the
overall service so we've seen
improvements in the quality of the
business improvements in the perception
of value for money improvements in the
service levels and the results
presentation today Tesco provided plenty
of data on consumer research showing how
their perception and the positive feel
about the company has improved massively
over the last few years is it a case of
them benefiting from the market growing
per se or are they actually winning
market share again now Tesco said that
they are now winning market share in
food again because you have to look
underneath the numbers to see what's
really going on one of the things have
been doing is de-emphasizing some of
their non-food offer in areas where they
don't make much money but within the
core food offer and inc all fresh foods
they are outperforming the market now
one of the features of food retailing is
it's an inelastic demand we tend not to
eat more calories from one year to the
next
we may eat more expensive or cheaper
calories flex around that but basically
there isn't much change in demand
overall so for one company to win
another has to lose so who do we think
they're winning chef Ron
well Tesco saying they're winning share
from most of the other members of the
big fall that Sainsbury's Morrison's and
an Asda they're unlikely to be winning
share back from the discounters at the
moment because the discounters are
opening substantial numbers of stores
but on a like-for-like basis Tesco will
be giving them a run for
money ie where take out the impact of
the new new stores and Tesco will be
competing very well really significant I
mean obviously everyone knows that the
local stores have been going pretty well
all these years the problem child were
the big-box hypermarkets and they've
even picked up growth there yeah that's
that's absolutely right and in part
that's to do with the the non-food offer
and the big-box stores were built before
the internet really had taken off but
now a lot of trade goes on onto the
internet and we're seeing a lot of high
street retailers struggle that's been
true of Tesco's non-food business and of
course it comes back to what I've just
said that they are focused on food and
driving their food sales D emphasizing
some of the non-food sales and if you
get a good food offer people will still
go to those big stores now clearly
they've patched up the core UK food
business which was the priority how are
they doing overseas I mean it's not
plain sailing there is it it's not plain
sailing and part of the problem is some
of the overseas businesses have got some
very large stores that don't actually
take a lot of money but when we look at
that there's been a good performance in
these figures both in Europe and in Asia
in Asia they are doing similar things to
the UK where the D emphasizing some of
their business that they don't make any
money on so they've reduced the amount
of wholesaling that they do and they're
focused on on being more competitive on
the core food offer and that's why on
the surface the sales appear to a fallen
not really on an underlying basis to the
consumer but the profitability is
getting better and all this of course
before Booker I mean how
transformational is that going to be a
book a transformational is an overused
word but this really is a
transformational business the new data
that tastes
Tesco gave today it was hidden in the
presentation is that they expect the
sales to grow from this I 2.5 billion
over the next several years now
Tesco talked about 200 million of buying
synergies but said the real reason for
this is not the synergies it's about
growing for the future and we expected
500 million of synergies many of which
would go back into improving price and
offer and that would drive the extra
Sara
two-and-a-half billion of extra sales
really is exceptional and given that has
to come from someone else that's great
news for Tesco it might be bad news for
the competition here for the others all
right Dave McCarthy always good to have
you on the show thanks that you honor me
later